黄度45
来这个有钥的扣
29块扣5扣5
29扣个5
袖子开上的这个
29块
扣5扣5
29扣5
这个领子上
简标的地方有个小洞呢
简标有个小洞
人民尼龙辉煌的一个稀显真知
这个是
胸围106
106 134
长度61
来这个不介意的9块扣个1
这样子的
9块9块
扣1扣1
9块钱扣个1
穿的一条白色的一条裤
来腰尾
腰尾66
66到88
腿尾104
肠肠36
肠肠36 裤肠88
来这个9块扣个8
9块9块
扣8 扣8这一条
夏天可以穿这一条裤的
9块
9块扣个8
9块9块
扣个8
9块扣8
来这个黄色
黄色这个袖子的话
是一个双层双层
这个威领威领一个
胸尾
胸尾116 124
116 124
来长度
前短后长95到102
这个
来这个29扣1
29块扣1扣1
两边还有口袋这个圈
黄色的
29扣个1
来这一块
这个是一个黑色
一个上衣
腰上这个中间是拼接的
腰上中间拼接这一块
来胸围
胸围100到116
100到116
来长度
6是8
9块不对不对
这个29块
29给你们
扣8扣8新款
这个是个新款
29块扣8扣8
29扣个8
29扣个8扣个8
来这一块
这一款
这个
这个是一个小翠花的一个短袖了
前面有个绑带
来
胸围
长度
长度62
来这个9块
9块扣2
9块9块
扣2扣2这一块
9块减1扣2而已
来这个
G2O唯一的这个M码又出来一条
看见没
这个牌子
黑白条
黑白条两边有写啥口袋的
来
腰围
腰围64到82
64 82
臀围106 116
3长
裤长98
来这个9块
9块扣个8这个扣就出来一条
还有谁要不
9块9块
扣8扣8
9块
扣8
来M码
M码M码
来
这一款
这个是一个
星色星色的一个大衬衣这个是我自留的一款
可以当防晒当衬衣都行
来
胸围
胸围120
胸围120长度
长度的话是73到78的一个长度了
来这个19扣8
扣8扣8这一块
19块
扣个8
19扣8
来这个黑色
来这个
7码7码
人年35
锯纸65送了一个背影扣这个是个7码黑色
来
胸围
胸围96
来
长度
来这个有要的9块
扣0扣0
9块扣个0
9块
扣个0
6块9块
来这个这个是一个蓝色圆领圆领的一个蓝色短袖学访的
来
胸围
胸围92100
来长度
长度54
9块钱扣0扣0
人哪人哪姐妹们人去哪里了
9块9块
扣0扣0
9块钱
扣个0
来这个打底
打底打底打底
打底
这个是一个墨绿色的一款打底
尺码大应该是个3L的应该
这一款的话有黑色橘色还有这个颜色
都是大码
3L也是3L的这一款
可以当打底也可以单穿
来
胸围
胸围108
108130长度65
这个9块
扣个5
9块9块
扣5扣5
9块
扣5扣5面料很软的这个打底
这个是一个短袖
后面有胶印的这一块
胸围
胸围116
长度70
来9块9块
扣个8
9块扣8
来
这一款
这个刚过了一件了这个19块
扣5扣5
这个我就不量尺寸了刚刚过了一个
扣5
来
这一款
这个是一个短袖了微顶微顶这一款短袖
微顶微顶两边是这样子的
看没
这两边是这样的打杆的
来
胸围
胸围是116134
来
长度61到67的长度
9块
扣8
9块扣个8
9块9块
扣8扣8
9块
扣8
来
来这一款
这个是风机扣有拉链的一条自动扣
这个是吗
刚刚谁要的这个小马这个是M码呢刚刚谁要的这一款裤子
这个是M码
来这个腰尾66到86
66 86腿尾112到120
三长37
裤长是100
这个又出来刚开播的时候谁问的这个又小码了
这个M码出来了
这个还不好这个腿上写字了呢
腿上写字了看到没
颜色很淡
来这个9块
扣6
9块给你炸了
39的这条裤
9块钱
有要的吗
后面应该在膝盖底啊膝盖后面
这个在后面腿后面有
有写的字
来这个39的这个裤
这个不介意的扣9块给你们了9块扣6
还可以在这个箱里面dan
Hit
好
从上面
又塑件
银层
是
不是
我
mood
版
洗
usage
是
hole
人呢咋没人说话了
这一会我的天哪
一个小时了
去一下洗手间去
借善好善
给你换首歌
听听我去下洗手间
这一会人少应该都在吃饭
电话就在睡觉
这一会都没人聊天
你看快一个小时了
没人跟我说话
去下洗手间
等我一下下
这一会人少应该都在睡觉
这晚风似曾吹
这夜的孤独的人拿她需要你一杯
让着当的丑子我
谁还没有睡
这一会人少应该都在睡觉
让着当的丑子我
凌晨三点醒来的夜 电话打给谁
这夜雨太温柔 这情话太不美
只是不美的情话 它究竟是给谁
嘻嘻嚷嚷的人潮 谁跟我醉了醉
爱也罢 恨也罢 聚散缘如水
这空荡的酒杯 清澈微醺的滋味
难受的情路太坎坷 却和我醉一回
这空荡的酒杯 是否也装过眼泪
那些遗憾错过的人 哪处定再也追不回
这空荡的酒杯 清澈微醺的滋味
好奇的情话 谁跟我醉了醉了
想找一个爱我的人 和我相依偎
这空荡的酒杯 含泊多少是与非
还是扇梦的承诺 最后全都化成灰
这夜雨太温柔 这情话太不美
只是无谓的情话 它究竟是给予谁